we follow the dan patrick show every
single day on nbc sports audio sirius xm
channel 211
and right here on peacock which is free
you go to peacocktv.com
and get it and the it is nbc sports
channel
and my buddy dan patrick of the dan
patrick show and more back here on the
show how you been dp
i'm good i'm good rich how are you i am
better for hearing your voice
i am better for hearing your voice um
so let's uh i don't know what what what
what do you decide about what you're
talking about these days this is helpful
to me and the crew here as well dan
after seven years we're sitting here
right in the middle of may
it seems like we're sitting around
waiting for aaron rodgers to talk while
the nba begins
what are you in the danettes uh hash
around to figure out this is what we're
going to talk about
on the show today i just
sort of take the temperature of
everybody and just say tell me what
you're really interested in because
you know ultimately it's a democracy
until it's a dictatorship
it's a democracy when we start the
morning and then it becomes a
dictatorship where i have to do it
yes but they understand this make your
case tell me what you're interested in
what guest are we going to go after and
and we have a back and forth throughout
the day
from from now until tomorrow morning and
then we'll come in tomorrow morning and
then
we sort of hit the reset button and
figure out
you know do we have any more information
on desean watson do we have any more
information on aaron rodgers
uh lebron says that he's not uh given
respect as one of the great scorers of
all time you have the play in game with
golden state
uh ron wolf the hall of fame gm formerly
the packers calling quarterbacks now
divas
you just sort of cobble it together and
you go okay do we have sound do we have
a guest
and how do we make this work usually for
uh
seven to ten minutes uh as long as this
segment might be well the thing
the problem i have with you know and i
know ron wolf's in the hall of fame and
so is terry bradshaw
but when you choose a quarterback in the
first round and trade up to go get a
quarterback in the first round
in 2020 under the current construct of
building a roster in the nfl and the
current collective bargaining agreement
of the nfl
under which ron wolf never built a team
and terry bradshaw never wanted to
play play to play it down that when you
do that
you have to put that kid on the field
you have to put that kid on the field by
year three
otherwise you are making a huge
financial bet on the kids future
for a fifth year option pickup that will
hamstring your team
with a guy that you don't know if it's
worthy or not
and we're already seeing a team like you
know the rams
and philadelphia sign their quarterback
who they drafted to
a nine-figure deal and then have to make
a big deal out of getting out of it
rogers has every right to say something
dan
in my estimate doesn't make him a diva
it makes him smart to try and
move his chess pieces around the board i
wonder what you think
but i don't know what makes you a diva
because russell wilson wanted to have a
seat at the table
and he you know understand when pete
carroll got to seattle didn't do well
first couple years
then they draft russell wilson russ has
cleaned up a lot of mistakes in seattle
because they've had some bad drafts and
i would think that russ
has earned that right to at least sit at
the table that doesn't mean
that he has the final say so or total
autonomy but i am curious
the guy is going to be sacked more than
any other quarterback in
history would like to talk about the
offensive line or offensive strategy
okay i'll give you a seat at the table
if aaron rodgers wants to talk about
what is our philosophy are we a run
first uh type offense
what kind of players are we going after
give him a heads up if you're going to
draft his
replacement i don't think i'd like
that we're not asking too much everybody
thinks oh my god tom brady's running the
buccaneers
tom brought in gronk and antonio brown
it's not like he said let me work out
tristan works at
offensive tackle and i i i think that
even mahomes it is my home saying
hey you gotta get me what offensive line
help
you don't need a seat at the table for
us to know we need to get you offensive
line help
wide receivers or whatever it might be i
i don't know if quarterbacks
how much of a station they have now do i
want to give to sean watson
say on who we should uh bring in to
interview
not particularly but i'll listen to is
his suggestion
i'm not going to let him say hey we're
going to hire that guy or i don't want
to play here
then he's gone too far but you know ron
wolfe
what it was a devil to him um
you know this is a new nfl back then
twenty years ago
thirty years ago you did shut up and
just play
uh but if dan marino's playing now joe
montana's playing
how would joe montana handle steve young
coming to the niners right
i mean you know and and and and he's
obviously
prior to brady winning seven the gold
standard
for quarterbacks along with bradshaw too
in terms of the number of super bowls
that they want dan and
and so again to sit here and how's
bradshaw done
if they brought in dan marino well he
pointed out that they drafted mark
malone in the first round in 1980
and and and bradshaw was still in his
late 20s where he just turned 30 and of
course he had all those trophies in the
case and he's like well i didn't pay
any attention to him and the reason why
he didn't have to is the financial
construct of the league was not set up
in such a way where it was essentially
mandated that malone get on the field
regardless of whether he deserved it or
not regardless of bradshaw's play
or not that jordan love and rogers knows
it
is going to have to get on the field in
order for that first round selection
to be paid off in any way shape or form
whether it's for the guy for the future
or to turn him into jimmy g
at least jimmy g got on the field so the
niners knew that he was worth the two
you know like that
that's why rogers is saying something
right now and i don't think that's
bad the packers bet and it looks like
they lost on two fronts they bet on
jordan
love and they bet that aaron rodgers
they bet against aaron rodgers
and they bet on jordan love and it looks
like they're losing both of those bets
jordan love is not ready and aaron
rodgers
won the mvp and i think they thought hey
his numbers are starting to
diminish and uh this will be the last
year
i truly thought they thought that this
was going to be his last year this past
season
and that jordan love would then be
elevated you know to the starters role
or at least
be in the on deck circle there's no
reason to draft a first-round
quarterback
if you can't take advantage of how much
you don't have to pay him
because after this i mean look at sam
darnold in carolina
if he has a good year what are you doing
with sam darnold
now all of a sudden i gotta go is he
worth a hundred million dollars
if i franchise him is he worth 35
million dollars
that's why carolina unless they think
they're getting deshawn watson or aaron
rodgers should have taken justin fields
in my opinion
dan patrick here on the rich eisen show
and you know again
that's the new construct of the nfl
where you you the owners said we're sick
and tired of paying a kid out of college
the most money in the history of our
franchise there's no other business in
america who doesn't like there's no
law firm that takes the top legal
scholar out of harvard and makes him or
her the highest paid
lawyer in the history of some wall
street firm you know what i mean like so
they
they wanted to at least see something on
the field before they had to make that
financial commitment to somebody
and now as you know you just pointed out
that there are some teams that have done
that in the eagles and the rams and now
they're
out of that you know and so so when
you're having people on your show as
much as you are
and cobbling together from news in
information
men and women and players and coaches
about what is the crux of the rogers
situation and how fixable is it
what do you think is going to happen
with this
dp you know my my
issue is that we haven't heard from
anybody who is
you know confirming validating any of
this
um you know if i take adam schefter at
his word
that aaron rodgers once out okay
but i don't i haven't heard from aaron
and i haven't heard from the packers
other than to say we're not
trading him i know the rams inquired i
know the niners inquired
and i think they were just on their due
diligence but does he
is he steadfast he'll never play for the
packers again
uh you know deshawn watson said that
look i'm not playing here again
and that you know of course might be the
case for a variety of reasons now but
until then it's really hard to sort
through this
and as you know we i spent 18 years at
espn where you had to have two sources
all the time when you're
going to you know give information
and if you speculate just by speculating
i've i put my name to it therefore
becomes
a report like it's not just hey i think
this may happen
damn patrick reporting that uh you know
aaron rodgers is going to stay like i
never want to get into that gray area
because
people are so hungry for information
and they're going to take and all of a
sudden a rumor in you annual
innuendo or a whisper or i'm here in
um it becomes more fact and and i don't
have any facts when it comes to
to aaron rodgers and i feel like i do a
disservice to the story
every time i do the story because i
really don't have an update hey i'm
hearing
denver would offer this or the raiders
would
have they offered that no
but i'm hearing they would i'm hearing
that aaron would like to go to vegas
okay until aaron says i want to go to
vegas
i can't believe that so you're sorting
through it
and it you know you it just feels like i
know less
every time i do the story no i know we
we've been equating it to that seinfeld
episode where his girlfriend looks
beautiful in one light and then in the
next light just not
not as pretty you know and and so
when it comes down to it you know the
nfl schedule makers are full speed ahead
they put the packers on a nationally
televised game
essentially uh for the first four weeks
so we're gonna have a front row seat to
this whole business
and i'm just assuming that the packers
are
are not gonna budge because that's their
history and rogers won't budge and
that's their history and and you might
see
i i i don't i don't know what the answer
is that do they send them a bouquet is
it like we're really really sorry for
drafting jordan love i mean
because that's the potentially unfixable
part about this
whole deal but i i would have traded
aaron rodgers
i you know i i i just i can't let one
player is great as he is i can't let him
hold us captive here
if we bet on jordan love then let's take
advantage of that situation and see if
he can play
it's unfortunate you have a nfc
powerhouse here a super bowl contender
but if
i would have thought about this earlier
i would have gone back to the night i
would have gone to the niners and said
before you trade all of these picks to
miami
move up to three send all of that
and jimmy g to green bay
now i i can have a transition that's not
going to be painful
that if jimmy g plays one year and then
we say goodbye jordan love we get two
years out of him
and then i get all these draft picks
here jimmy garoppolo is a
serviceable quarterback with a really
good roster
that you can still compete that's where
i would have gone with this
rogers is never going to be more
valuable than he is right now
and as much as it would pain me to get
rid of him or be the gm to say yep i
traded aaron rodgers
if you had traded him prior to an mvp
season
then i think people would have a little
bit more of a problem
and another thing rich if aaron rodgers
scores that touchdown against tampa bay
yes is he is he still upset
or not as of upset if they go to the
super like i don't i don't know
how it just i don't know there it just
feels like
there's some gray area here well taking
the two things you just said dan patrick
at dan patrick show we follow his show
at the emmy-nominated dan patrick show
every single day here on nbc sports on
peacock and nbc sports audio 211 that's
my reset to show how much of a
professional
i am to dan um that the two things you
just said there
number one is if you are correct if you
are correct that the packers do what you
just said and i think that that's a
smart decision
then you know the cap ramifications
of trading him back when the niners
might have knocked on their door
instead of trading all that to to miami
or on draft day
would have been so harmful certainly in
the the the
contracted uh cap year of after covid
um you know when we're obviously we're
still in it uh
it just could not have happened then so
i i would say june 1 will be
as the kids say lit if that happens
because that's
when that's when somebody like the
dolphins with their draft choices might
be able to go
and get aaron rodgers or even desean
watson if he's a viable quarterback
you know in the nfl and also a citizen
of the world
uh or the anybody the broncos could do
something like that as well so that
that will be june 1 to take a look at
that and then in terms of
losing to brady i think for sure
that brady winning in his house and
beating him
in that manner after they've dressed up
the window of opportunity remaining in
his career just fresh to the team
is what's really pissing aaron rodgers
off even more i think so
dan yeah but aaron had the home game
like he had the title game in his
backyard
thank you i mean you gotta win these
games and
now i can look at play calling but aaron
didn't handle that last drive well
and i do think they've helped him with
that roster i mean let's be honest they
haven't spent
spent you know their their first round
picks on skill position or on you know
offensive players
but their second third round pick
they've they've done really well
i mean devonta adams
uh jordy nelson
they've found receivers now you can say
does rogers make them better yes he does
but their offensive line is good aaron
jones
they kept aaron jones he didn't have any
brady yeah aaron john brady didn't have
any first round
skill position players for how many
years sixteen years
he won all those super bowls uh now did
he want it
yes did they have an offensive line that
they would just bring guys in
yes were they you know converting a
quarterback to a wide receiver
yes they did that you know did they get
a couple of really good tight ends or
certainly with gronk yes they did gronk
was a second round pick but
brady did it and you know they did find
players and i think with aaron
we tend to look at that roster and go
man he's done a whole lot with nothing
they they do have some good players and
a good offensive line and
some good skill position players i think
they've done right by him
they just owed him a heads up just to
say you know
like that's all just say look if this
player is there
like we just want you to know that we
really like him
and he's you know long-term whatever it
is it you may not like it
but if if you at least know about it
then they've thought
about you and i and he should understand
this they did this to brett favre when
he was there
so he should understand it i just think
he deserved
a heads up by by the front office before
i let you go dan patrick
uh what do you think of the playing
tournament you like it um
yeah you do yeah yeah well here's the
thing
if we didn't have by the way it's the
state farm plan
i need to get a pen my bad my dan
i i apologize to the insurance industry
my god writ large
don't don't let that happen again um
i i yes i like the plan but if
if you didn't have the lakers against
golden state then i don't think anybody
would
really care about the play in tournament
but you have lebron and steph tomorrow
night therefore
like yeah i like this i like this match
up here
if it's the wizards against the celtics
uh it's
the hornets against the pacers nobody
cares
you know the grizzlies against the spurs
nobody cares
but you got lebron against steph and
everybody thinks the play in tournament
is awesome
so i think it's this year it's awesome
let's see what happens next year because
i don't think you're gonna have this
perfect storm where
all the injuries and you're a seven seed
and you're gonna
hook up with a guy who's been incredible
and steph curry
uh it it might be uh a nondescript you
know final four or
front four or hope you know whatever the
uh play-in tournament is
uh next year and we won't get as much
excitement or headlines out of it all
right and i lied before i let you go now
for real
um the one one of the many things that
we do here on this show
that was uh taken from yours when we
were born uh on audience channel
is the poll question which went from
being online
uh on a website now on twitter so ask
dan patrick the poll question before we
get out of dodge here with dan
dan dan real quick who most needs to be
freed from their current team
aaron rodgers zion williamson shohei
i think rogers because it did it's it's
uncomfortable
uh for both sides it feels like where's
you know zion make good of it for as
long as you can
i mean and show hey otani would i like
to see him on a bigger stage yes
i think he may look and i i'd have to go
back
i think he may have chosen the angels
because it wasn't
as big a stage as if he gone to the
yankees of the dodgers
so that might suit his personality a
little bit more he's got a great manager
to play for
um would i like to see zion on a big
stage
nightly basis yes i i would but i
i would like to see if he can make it
work in new orleans because when you get
all these players
and then nobody cares about the
secondary markets here
i just don't think it's great for the
sport so i i i would say
rogers because both teams it feels like
could benefit from moving on dp
appreciate the time i'm i miss talking
to you
um so um i'd love to do this as often as
you'd like
and you know i don't know how often dan
beckley's on your program but i mean i'm
i'm
i'm up for calling into yours dan if
you're up for that
dad well that would that would be great
that that doesn't sound that
doesn't sound that doesn't sound like
you mean that and i'm being genuine
calling into your show
okay well i just said i didn't know if
it was as often as
i like her as often as you like so i was
just trying to figure that out
as often as i'd like which is you know
tomorrow what are you doing tomorrow dan
what are you doing what am i doing
tomorrow well you know we're cobbling
together
stories right now and
we're trying to figure out what what
we're going to do
can you listen to me when we started the
interview of how this works
yeah i did i did so that i'm i'm
i'm here to put that together i got
frizzy
like frizzy you know he's he's in
scramble mode always looking seeing what
story lines there are and
you know that if fritzy decides that he
wants rich eisen on the show then rich
eisen's on the go
oh but you're the dictator hey did is
that
brockman did the danettes want to fight
us
do you guys want to are you down on the
after show that the danettes are putting
together they threw they said they want
to fight us
is that true well we were talking about
floyd mayweather fighting what
paul yeah yeah both of them yeah
and then we thought okay who would we
fight on a celebrity match and
pritzy said the situation paulie said uh
that
uh that guy who uh put on the fire
festival
uh mcfarland yeah okay yeah billy
mcmillin
mclovin said that he would fight stu
gotz from the dan
levitard show i paid for that one and
and then seton said that he was going to
fight
um del tufan yeah
i mean oh my gosh it was just kufo
like i would i would if i had to fight
you on the
undercard i would do it but i i wasn't i
wasn't calling for that no i understand
because i i understand i i would be
there
in your mind certainly the jake paul of
that scenario and i don't know if
i'm um you know i'm not no i didn't want
to do that i mean i
i i'm just saying that your name came up
only by proxy because seaton wanted
to kick deltoofo's out
okay i'm training dan he's a lover not a
fighter i love her so are we too no i
i have seen you with your pants off
it's been a while you guys might want to
go to break here
thank you dan you take care all right
buddy bye
there you go there's dan patrick
everybody hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here